I've always believed in putting the most
important people in my life things I've
been through my kind of marking on my
body no one really understands you know
when you experience her things in life
they wonder why you do certain things I
don't think I was thinking to my mind
was like if something ever let it be it
was an accident or some natural or
whatever I just hope she wasn't murdered
this is to be like my whole little
stomping ground growing up right this
whole neighborhood
this stupid
I won't come back around here as much
hell with all that growing up in Decatur
was what you make it my mom was raising
three kids without father figure around
so it was kind of like being a product
of your environment
that's one thing about it you definitely
grew up fast you earn your stripes early
there's a new record four murders
committed in DeKalb County
breaking news in Northwest Lee say he
was shot eight times after a violent
week the situation police are on the
scene of a deadly double shooting if you
name it I've done it I actually broke it
to a car one day and the car had a gun
in it and you know I got the gun out the
car and you know I came home and I gave
it some older brother and I was like you
know yo look what I got so you know it
hasn't been the older brother I really
didn't want the gun I gave it to him he
took the gun to school I thinking like a
couple days later and he actually shoots
someone with it another one the craziest
things I did was actually me and my
friend stole a car and we pulled up to
the pawn shop and we tied a chain around
the pawnshop door and put it on the
pickup truck and the truck pull it off
and it broke the door I'll be winning
that grabbed a bunch of guns and whole
bunch of stuff and then we took off and
at that time I'm like 11 years old and
I'm just doing it to be stupid I didn't
even want any guns I just did it because
I thought it was cool
that right there cuz I got you 10 20
years ago the biggest trace my mom had
was something that is priceless she just
always had our back like no matter what
it was I remember coming to get me up
from juvenile one day and she blatantly
asked me did I steal something and I
said yes and she was like well how did
you do they didn't catch you stealing it
and I was like knows Mike Scioscia fight
well you ain't stealing it the biggest
thing with that man she's always out on
back house to me was like the most
important trait I ever forget from my
mother she got into are you much trying
to make a better life for us so you know
she she made a lot of sacrifices you
know I used to have days where I was
going on my room and see no cocaine
stacked up those days well go to my
mom's cheddar are safe in her room and
it was thousands of thousands of dollars
stacked up my mom was getting a little
money and that's when certain things
changed you know he moved into this
bigger home and that's when certain
things happen fourth of July I was
standing my grandfather's house and we
call it and she didn't picked the phone
up we got her in the car and it was
going over there and even the whole way
over I just had this weird feeling like
someone write and someone's been put in
the drawer I could just sense something
was like one cooling and I got the key
my sis was like going I opened the door
and like someone's I open a do it was
like
something right in here and then I took
a couple steps in the house and I look
to the left and then it was just very
quiet it was like so quiet that you can
hear like a like the crack in the wall
like you know saying like a weird sound
and I just took a right and look right
down hall and I just saw my mom laying
in a fetal position or yellow pants and
a white shirt
you see blood on the wall I paused I was
I was stunned because I was like
everything went to my head like oh my
god go uncle help her or somebody else
and how did she get murdered like
everything was just spinning around my
head and I'm just sitting here and my
natural essence was round house and get
help
sent outside for like an hour and the
police officer came out and he told us
they said it wasn't breaking and
entering and she came in and she got
shot a few times I went ahead and went
in the back arm something like that and
then I just remember this just this dart
like just feeling like if I even miss
this there it was like man like who did
that and I just cried I don't think I
slept for like two days and this is at
13 years old I was like the person loved
most like I gone you know there was what
it was when I was I was most emotional
day of my life
when the police did to report an
investigation there was someone she knew
that she let in the house and that was
really like wow like that person is
still out that person can beat that
person who did it could have came to the
funeral in person you can see right now
we wouldn't even know it
after the funeral it was like my whole
life changed I wanted my uncle my life
got better like a 14 year old kid being
born again when I'm moving up there my
whole family everybody plays sports my
uncle was like you're gonna play for
Christmas I want to get away your mom
said if you're gonna make me play this I
might as well get big and strong and I
just thought lifting weights like it was
no other I started getting developed
many of my body and start building up
confidence and I remember we have trials
and we went to practice and I ran over
and wanted up the kids late was
so-called supposed to be the best one on
the team and from that day on the one
don't looking back
anxious to see what the house look like
I haven't been back over here in years
long time it's like it looks different
but I remember certain things about it I
wonder where they left me in this house
though that's why I was bring the crazy
house is uphill enough somewhere yeah
I remember this house you know right
here
when the police came to the house we
were sitting right here and we was
parked this way and I was in the
backseat and I remember the officer
walking down through here and he was
like you know I got some bad news and my
sister was like please don't say the
murder of the money he was like yes it
was a murder she was murdered and shot
and then that's when I like like blacked
out like I remember and it was raining
it was like real gloomy and rainy and I
was the day and I never came back and
said his house like from that day this
is the closest I've been to this house
since since she passed away even this
part bring back crazy memories this is
where I came in there right here open
this little gate
how you doing
I play professional football and I grew
up in his house I get it I know but it's
a hell of a story
DLC ket so you can look it up are you
going to google it up go go get up do CE
o DLC ket to em they just wanted to like
film in the house with there's just no
privacy oh I get it
that's cool maybe another time we
figured out yeah okay nice to meet you
okay wait all right hey it was like whoa
and I was looking through the crack of
the door
and I could see that that interest went
out when I heard that crack sound
through the left side of the house but
um
sorry it's a weird feeling deficit all
over yeah yeah and I anyone to tell her
that it's my dad house I don't wanna put
that on nobody so that's that my mom had
a lot of no a lot of years to live a lot
of exciting is a lot of enjoy me is
you've always said you know would you
give it all that your mom back and I
can't I said I would know what comes
with this life and that life is more
real to me
their life is authentic have your mom in
New Jersey come into games my Mother's
Day picking your mom taking out to
dinner also giving my kids a grandmother
you know nothing like a grandmother love
that's the big thing and I wish I could
do is give my kids a grandmother
especially you know to be able to say
him one of my grandma's house for the
weekend and watch my mom babe explore my
my kids so things that I really really
wanted when I look back at my mom she
made a lot of sacrifices with with drugs
are working and doing all these things
to give us a better life in the end of
course in our life
whoever took my mom's life Know Who I am
they ain't not dumb I made enough noise
I would still want to know that it even
if just AI would be introduced to sit
down have a conversation where I'm like
you know what was my mom's last words
and what was you thinking whatever you
try to accomplish
you could have accomplished without
taking her life reach out to me you know
talk to me and ain't no no I I get
someone to take your life that's easy if
they do things you know just reach out
to me you know talk to me you know I
forgive you